on the mound for the angels is
right-handed dylan bundy four and two
third in the al with a 2.470 ra and
seven starts so two on and nobody out
for michael brantley
uses the change up a lot more to the
lefties here's one chopped on the left
side fielded by simmons flips the second
one relay to first and that is a nifty
double play right there
boy sammy
on the mound for the astros with a
record of three and two and a 5.06 era
is right-hander lance mccullers jr so
let's see what mike trout can do
that is drilled out towards straightaway
center field springer racing back to the
wall that one is gone
big fly for mike trout and move over tim
salmon you have company atop
the angels home run leaderboard number
299.
see him i'm coming
i'm coming
hit that ball i was
sick the colors after giving up the
trout homer has walked the next three so
the bases are loaded and here comes
dusty baker and that's going to be it
for
lance mccullers dusty has seen enough he
is going to go to the bullpen lance does
not record an out in this start there is
a little concern about something going
on with his finger or his hand to begin
with
so luis garcia is going to come into
this game make his major league debut
for the astros
and he comes in with the bases loaded
nobody out
bottom of the first two nothing angels
and jared walsh the batter
this one out to left field not very deep
kyle tucker is there rendon tagging he's
coming home
the throw is cut off sac fly for jared
walsh and it's three nothing angels like
that aggressiveness right there you pick
up a sac fly for walsh and the batter
now franklin barretto
called third strike gets the edge there
it is the first career strikeout for
luis garcia
walsh will be the next batter
1-1 on walsh's falls driven into center
field this one is carrying deep out
there and it is out of here
dead center
off the bat there jared walsh
that is only his second career home run
he had won last year for the angels his
first this season and boy did he ever
put a charge into that one
angels
increased the lead it's now four nothing
so here's barretto stepping up he was
called out on strikes his first time up
that ball is hit sharply backhanded by
correa nice play carlos correa to get
franklin barretto to end the inning
carlos continues to play elite defense
so here's the man you won at the plate
right now kyle tucker 19 rbis in his
last 13 games
bundy first pitch in on the hands and
grounded to the right side it's the
first baseman walsh he'll take it
himself it's a ground out but an rbi for
tucker and the astros are on the board
that brings up correa gray grounded out
his last time up hit it well here's the
pitch
and that ball's ripped to left field
that's going to be
off the wall off the base of the wall
for correa guriel will score easily and
correa cruises into second base with an
rbi double
and now the angels lead down to four to
two and the next spatter for the angels
will be anthony rendon
on the ground towards the hole carlos
correa makes the play for one and the
return not in time
so now we're in heathrow in scoring
position for simmons who's one for three
with a single
shot to right field a base hit
brenhifa will come around to score and
the angels have a 5-2 lead second hit of
the night for angelton simmons just like
that another multi-hit game and another
clutch hit with a runner in scoring
position for simba
so they're going to leave in
bundy to face reddick
he's ready takes a look at second here's
the 2-2
and he got him looking and that will end
the inning so he strikes out the side
they got the lead off double and then
bundy
putting kays up against the
astros here in the seventh bottom of the
seventh is next now it brings up reddick
who's one for four pitch on the way and
that's inside and off the glove of
breseno maldonado will score springer
goes to third and it is five to three
angels
1-0 and redick bounces once softly right
side this will get the run in fielded by
walsh he takes it to first himself and
there is one out in the inning but
springer scoring makes it five to four
angels astros trail the angels five to
four two runs home in the inning and
julie guriel at the plate he's two for
four with a run scored breaking ball
broken back little loft fly ball to
shadow left and here comes taylor ward
makes a sliding catch nice
by taylor ward
kyle tucker the last hope for the astros
tucker hooks one down the line and right
that's a fair ball going all the way to
the wall straw will score work tied at
five the astros down to their final
strike tie it up thanks to kyle tucker
so one out
trout still at second the winning run
shohei ohtani at the plato for four with
a wall
the 3-2 johay pulls one into right field
that's a base hit trout it's going to be
waved around
drive home safely everybody
angels win it six to five shohei ohtani
with the walk-off hit